thorsten frei für die union würde wie
man sich normalität zurück wünschen
würde dann würden wahrscheinlich viele
sich die situation von anfang letzten
jahres wünschen wir erleben das
natürlich in den gesprächen mit den
bürgerinnen und bürgern und auch an uns
selber wie die pandemie zu schaffen
macht und wie die pandemie auch müde
macht und wenn man das mit einem
marathon vergleichen wollte dann müsste
man vielleicht sagen wir sind jetzt bei
kilometer 38
da wo den marathonläufer die typische
krise erfasst und wo man glaubt es gibt
überhaupt kein ende mehr
obwohl in drei kilometer das licht am
ende des tunnels zu sehen ist und dieses
licht am ende des tunnels das heißt
impfen bei uns das ist es impfen wie man
sich hier hinstellen kann und sagen kann
wo ist denn der turbo wo wir vorgestern
738 1501 impfungen in deutschland hatten
dass es mir schleierhaft wir kämpfen und
wir legen zu und das ist das licht am
ende des tunnels aber die wahrheit ist
halt eben auch alleine zu impfen reicht
nicht da kann man den blick quentin
beispielsweise nach israel nach
großbritannien in die usa oder jetzt
auch nach chile die alle eine höhere
impfquote haben als deutschland und voll
in der dritten welle sind das allein
reicht nicht
deswegen ist es unverantwortlich wenn
wir jetzt nicht die notwendigen
begleitmaßnahmen ergreifen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und ich
fand es total interessant zum stichwort
impfen ich fand das total interessant
dass hier der fraktions vorsitzende der
sozialistischen fraktion die usa als
leuchtendes vorbild beim impfen
hinstellt wir sind diejenigen die
verantwortung nicht nur für uns selbst
übernehmen sondern auch für andere
länder
die usa tun dies nicht darüber kann man
denken wie man will aber dass die
sozialistische fraktion genau das als
leuchtendes beispiel hervorhebt das ist
dann links populismus wirklich nicht zu
überbieten
das war eine
schlimme rede lieber herr barth stieß
sie hier gehalten haben und ich will an
dieser stelle noch etwas anderes sagen
hier hin zu stehen und von der abbruch
birne des parlamentarismus zu sprechen
wo wir hier ein gesetz vorlegen das
parlament so viele möglichkeiten gibt
wie nie zuvor
wir regeln als bundes unmittelbares
gesetz wie es sorgen dafür dass wolf
rechtsverordnungen ermöglichen dass der
bundestag diese löschte diesen zustimmen
muss der parlamentarismus geht doch
überhaupt nicht sagen sie doch mal wie
sich denn eigentlich gerne hätten nichts
aber auch gar nichts dazu gesagt herr
kollege
der kollege ernst würde jan eine
zwischenfrage stellen gerne herr kollege
und ich dachte daher ernst wollte eine
frage stellen
doch das war dazu dass ernst für ihn
schon noch jafry gut
diese erste ich muss ihnen sagen die
auslage gegenwärtigen sich hier
vollzogen haben dieses gesetz ist hier
vorgelegt wird ist letztlich nichts
anderes als dass bundestag beschließen
soll dass die regierung machen kann
diese frage was sie will
und insofern ist es alles andere als
eine stärkung des parlaments das nichts
anderes als dass dass die regierung
einen freibrief für maßnahmen die höchst
umstritten sind und auf einen möchte ich
sie mal aufmerksam machen sie wissen
ganz genau dass wir verschiedene
kontakte haben die tatsächlich zu mehr
infektionen führen wir haben die
industrie wir haben die wirtschaft da
gibt es faktisch null beschränkung
sie sind nicht mal in der lage in dieses
gesetz rein zu schreiben dass man doch
bitteschön testen muss bevor man sich am
arbeitsplatz auffällt und bevor man sich
möglicherweise so verhält dass man
andere ansteckt warum schreiben sie
diesen trend
wissen sie was sie continental weil sie
den
unternehmerverbänden im wind zu hängen
das ist die tatsache und ich sagte sie
ist deshalb so schlimm
das ist deshalb so schlimm herbei weil
gleichzeitig werden wir hier zum
einkaufen geht da brauche ich ein test
dass ich ein kaufhaus gehen kann das
publikum rein wenn ich in den
einzelhandel gebrauch gegen tesch und
comic con in raaba industrie wo sich
täglich 40 millionen abhängig
beschäftigten tummelt und andere
anstecken können dort drücken sie die
augen zu und sagen die sollen doch
machen was sie wollen unmöglich und
jetzt habe ich sehr geschätzt hieß es so
kann man das klick machen erfahren könig
bleiben sie bestehen
so sind die regeln wieder herr kollege
ernst ich will die frage gerne
beantworten sie sollten vielleicht sehen
dass wir nicht nur das vierte
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz machen sondern
eine reihe von anderen gesetzen wo wir
auch regelungen im bereich des
arbeitsrechtes und des schutzes am
arbeitsplatz drin haben
der zweite teil ihrer frage wie kommen
sie eigentlich auf die idee dass wir
hier ein gesetz machen das ein freibrief
für die bundesregierung bedeutet nein
wissen sie dass die zwischenrufe von
ihnen kommen wundert mich nicht weil vor
wenigen wochen vor wenigen wochen haben
genau sie so argumentiert wie das der
herr ernst jetzt macht nur falsch
bleiben falsch falsch falsch
wir möchten gerne im bundes
infektionsschutzgesetz einen paragraphen
28b machen im absatz 1 stehen zehn
maßnahmen drin
das hat nicht die bundesregierung
entwickelt das hat die
bundestagsfraktion der union und der spd
vorgeschlagen und stellen das hier heute
und am kommenden mittwoch zur abstimmung
das entscheidet das parlament und im
absatz 6 da steht eine
verordnungsermächtigung drin und zwar
unter dem zustimmungsvorbehalt von
bundesrat und bundestag was ist denn
daran ein freibrief für die
bundesregierung wenn sie ins gesetz
schauen dann sehen sie dass das nichts
aber auch rein gar nichts mit der
wahrheit zu tun hat was sie hier sagen
[Applaus]
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das was
wir hier vorlegen das ist ein mix
unterschiedlicher maßnahmen weil wir
ganz genau wissen dass nicht eine
einzige maßnahme die wirkung erzielen
wird sondern nur die summe aus diesen
wirkungen aus diesem ziel
und wenn sie jetzt hingehen und einzelne
maßnahmen herausgreifen diskreditieren
und mit gutachten kommen die ihnen
gerade in den kram passen
das hat auch die fdp gemacht das hat
auch der herr link gemacht dann ist das
einfach nicht in ordnung sondern dann
sollten sie das gesamte pc tieren wir
haben sehr gute gutachten beispielsweise
aus kanada
da hat man untersucht die provinzen
quebec und ontario in die welt gibt es
eine ausgangs beschränkung und da hat
man festgestellt dass im vergleich zur
provinz ontario
die bewegungen zurückgegangen sind um
31% das führt dazu dass die
reproduktionsrate um 13 prozent
zurückgehen und das wiederum führt dazu
dass nicht durch die ausgangs
beschränkung alleine aber durch die
ausgangs beschränkung in einem bündel
von maßnahmen
die rede produktionsquote zurückgeht und
wir damit das erreichen dass das
gesundheitssystem entlastet wird und
insel insbesondere die intensivstationen
denn das ist doch offensichtlich dass
hat ja hier noch nicht einmal jemand
bestritten dass wir die hilferufe der
unfall und notfall und und
intensivmediziner nicht in den wind
schlagen dürfen wir haben ständig
steigende belastungen auf den
intensivstationen
der höchststand von 6.000
intensivpatienten mit coop 19
er wird wahrscheinlich noch in diesem
monat erreicht deswegen der einzige satz
der wichtig war in der rede vom herr
bartsch war der dass er gesagt hat wir
haben zehn nach zwölf und nicht zehn vor
zwölf das ist zutreffend es ist richtig
und daraus muss man doch auch
konsequenzen ziehen und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben heute
die erste lesung dieses gesetzes es ist
nur ziemlich impulsive debatte die wir
hier erleben das ist auch vollkommen in
ordnung aber ich möchte einfach dazu
aufrufen dass wir uns alle
zusammenreißen und vor dem hintergrund
dieser analyse die weitestgehend geteilt
wird in den nächsten tagen auch daran
arbeiten dieses gute gesetz noch besser
zu machen
und auch hier sage ich lieber bereichen
ihnen ausdrücklich die hand wir wollen
gemeinsam mit ihnen schauen wie wir
dieses gesetz noch besser und noch
effektiver machen können und natürlich
vorher in äcker gibt's da ansatzpunkte
wo man etwas tun kann sie haben das
thema der schulen angesprochen
ja das ist noch keine gute lösung die
können wir noch besser machen und auch
an der ein oder anderen stelle wird es
genauso gehen wir werden am ende
natürlich auch sehen müssen am ende
braucht jedes gesetz hier im deutschen
bundestag eine mehrheit
und wie schwierig das ist
zeigt auch die heutige debatte und im
übrigen in richtung die der
bundesratsbank gerichte diese debatte in
dieser woche und den nächsten tagen
zeigt natürlich auch dass es auch die
ministerpräsidenten in den letzten
wochen und monaten nicht leicht hatten
sondern dass es halt einfach eine
objektiv schwere aufgabe ist diese
unterschiedliche zielkonflikte
zueinander zu bringen
aber das ist jetzt unsere verantwortung
und diese verantwortung gibt uns auch
unsere verfassung das sollte meiner der
stelle nicht vergessen also okay ich
dachte der präsident ich verstehe jetzt
was er meint und deswegen komme ich zum
ende und sage hier liegt ein gutes
gesetz vor wir sollten hart daran
arbeiten dass weiter zu verbessern und
dafür bitte ich um ihre unterstützung
und ihren konstruktiven beitrag
herzlichen dank